he's a better Defender I think is an
all-run package what you're looking for
I think Trent's better than every one of
them
sorry
that's making the ending
[Music]
hello my name is Laura Woods that's Anna
Shira and that's Jamie carragher just in
case you didn't recognize the two of
them eyelabs this is Sport Bibles 11 and
we are going to get ready to pick our
formation our team ahead of the first
World Cup game England against Iran the
way it's set out at the moment obviously
this is how we think our Southgate is
going to set out the England side three
at the back whether or not you love it
or you hate it it's for the Iran team so
would you like to disagree with the
formation first of all
yeah I wouldn't play through the back
well we haven't got three good enough
Defenders so I would go with two
um that's that's that would be our main
problem
um
so I would go with with four and a
sitting Midfield and
and let's face it whatever we whatever
he plays or we play three or four at the
back we should
beat your run fingers crossed Famous
Last Words Jamie yeah I agree with Alan
I would go to a back four because of the
opposition and know the manager has been
playing about three it's caused a lot of
discussion but it normally plays a back
three in big games and tough games you
go back to the Euros I think he did
against Germany and in the final against
Italy so I actually think the fact he's
been playing three at the back of late
it's best against Italy in Germany
lately
is as you're almost getting ready for
The Knockout rounds in some ways and I
just think it wouldn't be the right
signal to sense to set out back three in
that first game so back four for me it's
a very very short turnaround isn't it
from the last Premier League game to the
first game in the World Cup for for all
teams but for everyone that's involved
in the Premier League not much of a
break I think it's a joke I mean the
fact that the world cup is
gone to Qatar the fact that it's in the
middle of the season I think there's
going to be so many players are going to
miss out on a tournament that is
something that you wait for every four
years obviously and there's something
that you know players dream of when
they're a kid of playing it and there's
going to be injuries not just in the
Premier League right across the world
because there's such a sure turn around
and it might only be a 10-day tubic
injury and you're gonna miss a World Cup
okay boys I'm gonna allow you guys so
now just move your formation because you
had a back four you had one sitting
didn't you yeah would you like to agree
on that yes everything is going fairly
well right now isn't it feels a little
bit odd for you to agreeing on
everything but fine having it sort of
like that yeah yes happy yes okay guys
so we're going to move on now and start
to pick the players that are going to
make this formation up for you against
Iran first game of the World Cup
we're going to start with right back
because it feels like actually that's
probably had the most discussion around
it as we head into it so Alan I'm going
to let you go first on this one who
would be your number one choice bearing
in mind it's for that first game
if if he's fit it would be Kyle Walker
um
the the debate about around the right
back is is is huge if if everyone's fit
because we've we've got so many talented
players in that uh in that position all
offer uh different things
um but because of what he's done in the
past because of where he plays who he
plays for
um then I would probably I would start
with Kyle Walker in that right back
position that might surprise a few
people just with your Newcastle
there's a there's an if coming in if
he's not fit I would have out before
I'll go any further I would have TripIt
in my team if he's not going to be right
back I'd have him left him there I would
definitely have him in my team if if
Walker's not fit I would have a head of
anyone else in the right back position
we've seen Gareth playing at left back
but we're going to do the right back
position for now so obviously you know
what's coming that left back from from
Alan what do you think for you who's
your right back
I agree with Alan in terms of Kyle
Walker I think it would have been
familiaries James but I don't think he's
going to make it I think Kyle Walker is
going to be touching goal but in return
about the Iran game
and get on the ball and trying to break
someone down putting balls in playing
clever through passes I think it has to
be Trend right what about if england is
the play Trend in England win four or
five nil Trent sets three up then how
are you going to leave them out with the
next game well the one after that it's
not my job
also on on that topic we did see the
group stages in the Euros we did see
Gareth almost play a different team
defensively the center-backs to the to
once we got into the knockout stages so
it's almost like thanks very much now
it's getting seriously well that could
be what he does with with a Kyle Walker
and maybe fingers crossed the Reese
James if he could make us that's what he
did to Harry MaGuire Hannah McGuire
wasn't ready for the Euros I think
Tyrone Ming started the tournament but
in terms of the Iran game I like trippy
I think he's a good player but the thing
of you know I think he played left-wing
back as well in the Euros I don't see
the left wing back thing with Kaden
Shippy I think it's a right back he's a
very good Premier League player steady
player he's done better in an English
yet I would say than Trent Alexander
Arnold but I think in terms of doing
something a little bit special a little
bit different against opposition we're
going to be deep and negative
I think the players have to pick on his
trend
I don't I don't I don't see a great deal
of difference between Trent and trippy
in terms of
set pieces it's fantastic at only score
last season this season
set one up or set a few up
um assists wise crosses he's a better
Defender I think is an all-run package
what you're looking for
I think Trent's better than every one of
them
sorry that's
okay guys so we're both agreeing that
walk is going to be a right back yes yes
yeah and so you worried me we've just
argued over Trend and none of us have
picked him
he starts a conversation though doesn't
he but he'll be on the plane for you
right he'll be in the squad
for both of you Trent yeah yes okay
excellent there you go so there's our
first choice it's a combined 11 for both
of you so you can argue it out I haven't
said this actually yet but where you
don't agree with it I get to make the
deciding vote which gives me a lot of
power yeah here we go so the next
position that I want you guys to pick is
um your two center-backs now this again
is a big discussion let me to be honest
there's discussions all over the pitch
or at least we hope so to make this a
good video
Jamie I'm Gonna Let You Go first here
because you know this position so tell
me who would be your number one pick at
Center back
it's not easy I think before the number
one pick would always be Harry MaGuire
for Garrett Southgate and what he's done
in tournaments for England but on the
back of what happened in the last couple
of Internationals how it's gone from
Manchester United really difficult to to
pick him I think John Stones goes in
there
but again John Stones hasn't really been
playing Center back at Man City and
playing fullback and again he's just
come back from injury so I think John
Stones becomes the first pick and then I
think they want to go alongside him
could be absolutely anybody
really I think it could be any you could
make a case for attic dire yeah you
could look a kind of coldie these are
the players who will be in the squad
Harry MaGuire I'm not sure on on what we
saw in the last two Internationals
really uh but
what else can go to Salt cake do I think
you're right in terms of I wanted your
thoughts obviously about in a back four
that you'd feel like Stone's probably
the more comfortable the other ones a
lot of the other options Poseidon that
you see are more comfortable in a back
three maybe yeah who is he your number
one as well storms is definitely my my
number one
um Harry has done incredibly well Harry
MaGuire has done incredibly well for
England
um
over recent tournaments and we know
Gareth likes to go to his favorites who
have who have served him well in the
past and and Harry MaGuire has but
if you if you're not playing
Club football
it's a huge huge Gamble and a huge ask
of the individual to be thrown into a
World Cup the biggest tournament ever
without having any games behind you
would you also be a bit concerned with
the way that his form has dropped off
about where his head is at the moment
and and confidence with that big
Spotlight of a World Cup yeah absolutely
I mean I I know more than most that form
particularly for England
shouldn't really count because leading
up to year 96 I haven't scored for
England for two years well I didn't even
know that so you're just showing your
ears
yeah I hadn't scored for two years for
England so I understand the clamor and
the urge to leave people out in terms of
when you're talking of about former
still scoring for for Blackburn but um I
just think if you're not if you're not
playing uh Club football to then be
thrust into the biggest competition of
them all in the World Cup irrespective
of the opposition
well let's put him down because you both
agree yeah and John stones and now let's
look at who's going to play beside him
so do you want me to I mean you've got
Eric Dyer you've got Mark Gay here as
well Crystal Palace Gomez one of your
boys Connor Cody actually Connor Cody
right now
playing as well or better than every
other English Center Mac because I think
to be fair I think the other one you put
alongside it was maybe Eric died in the
middle of that back three for Conte but
um what kind of cool he's gone for
Everton alongside tarkov he's almost
changed the narrative around that club
and how they're seen
but
I then look at stones and kind of Cody
and in some ways feels two similar
players there's no real sort of
Powerhouse if you like so you think of
eerily set pieces they're both good on
the ball read the game really well
so I think that might go against Conor
uh
and then when you read those names out I
can't able to go back to Maguire but
it's difficult not to because of what
he's done for England in tournaments but
again as you said if you played this
sort of
the focus and the attention
you mentioned the two friendlies if you
had it played well in those friendlies
then there would be no debate yeah but
because of his performance and what he
did giving the ball away the penalty
away the backlash after that and the
criticism
for him personally
I think has affected his conference
hugely and you're not you're not I don't
care what anyone says you're not seeing
the same player when he's out on the on
the pitch and his confidence has been
affected okay Joe so we need a final
answer from you who is your other Center
back Eric Dyer
I find it very I find it difficult to
argue against that as much as I'd like
to
um the options that we've I mean one
other name I'd like to put in is done
burn I mean
Cara's mentioned Cody and tarkowski it's
Everton a formerly good partnership
um I'll if you're talking those two then
I'd have to Chuck his name in because
he's been Sensational from Newcastle
whether it's been left back or sent to
half
um but
I mentioned
Harry MaGuire and how tough it is for
him to to play so I would have to go
along with dyer as well so Eric
and I know that makes you angry that
makes you angry okay um we're gonna move
further up now and we're gonna go to the
front through because I imagine at this
position which you know very well I
don't think there's going to be much
complaint about who's going to start up
here can I have the guest at Harry Kane
yes yeah
one world class player at this moment
uh
uh how would I would add another one in
there I would have forden in there I
think he's world-class as well
um but yeah Harry came
is is as good as there is around in
terms of putting the ball in the back of
the net because there's no one better
than him and if yeah if this England
team are going to do well he has to be
firing and he has to put the ball on the
back then okay so Harry Kane's gonna go
down there and um I just wondered
whether or not you feel like he's
England's best number nine in history
hmm it's good
but he's but he's not that good
not as good as Rooney
put him in that list then
um
Rooney would be the top for me I mean
he's I was a he I don't think it could
be anything but a huge fan of uh of
Rooney I mean he'll get his the records
as but he scored more goals hasn't he
yeah yeah um I just think what what
Rooney gave us in terms of everything
and could do a little bit different
could also put the ball on the back of
the net
um but this is I mean how can you not
admire what he's done and what he's
going to do because he's got a good few
years left what's the differences
between him and yourself rather than
Rooney
he would link up player more in terms of
coming deeper certainly more in the last
two or three years he's done that
um
he needs to do it a little bit more as
well because he's going to get my record
if he steers right up top again and gets
he uh gets all those goals that's I
think that's his difference he can play
he can play in the 10 roll as well as
the nine rule I didn't like doing that I
didn't like doing that does the fact
that he hasn't won a trophy does that
change your view of him only people use
that I don't but his view of him as a
pleasure to take anything away from him
no because that I mean I know I won the
Premier League but that was the watch
chucked at me for not going to man
united imagine all the trophies I mean
he
I'm not any less happier when I'm 52
years of age that I haven't won all
those trophies like the man united boys
one I was I was more than happy with my
decision and going to Newcastle and
achieving what I did I know what
Tottenham means to him he'll have a
statue he loved their record he'll have
any he loved Lord probably yeah yeah he
probably will yeah what will you do when
he gets it will you sit down and have a
cigar and a strong drink and just
reflect on your career
I'll be the first to shoot it's going to
go one day so I'll be the first to shake
his hand and congratulate him I've had
it for 30 odd years
okay let's go to this position here
because um there might be a bit more of
a debate around these two positions up
front
Alan who would be your number one sucker
definitely uh having a
great time with Arsenal has proved he
can handle it mentally after what
happened to him in the Euros came back
stronger
so for me definitely on that right
search for him peace direct can create
can score
to Osaka excellent choice
the reason I agree is because I think it
all revolves around Harry Kane is the
absolute guarantee he's going to play
every game and Harry Kane as you know
what Allen's mentioned he's always
coming deep with the ball as he's
getting older he's fantastic at getting
on the ball but then you need people
running behind you need Pace in behind
hurricane because if you have another
player in that position who is coming
for the ball as well you've got no
penetration in behind so for me the two
people you'd look at straight away are
fold and suck at but I actually think
Fordham comes deeper for the ball at
different times he's a great player and
I'll mentioned before he's the other
whale class player in the squad
but he hasn't really shown that for
England I think sack has done more for
England than Phil Ford now so if it was
one or the other on that side I would go
for soccer I like that we were getting a
full demonstration there like
that like yes I feel like you're going
to get the touch screen out any second
right second on the right we don't have
them on Match of the day
you look don't like standing up you're
just comfortable sitting it's over on
the left who are we going for Jamie why
don't you start with this one well it's
two for me it's whether they're Fallen
plays on this side or Raheem steel and
again I go back to if you're asking me
is Phil Ford a better player than sake
yes is he a better player than making
him stealing yes but it hasn't quite
happen for him in England [ __ ] now I've
seen Phil Fulton actually being
devastating on this left side and the
pace he's got to run in behind
but Raheem still has done it for England
and that showed that the conundrum for
me stealing is very penetrating making
runs in behind Kane
but he struggled at Chelsea's found it
tough
and it just feels like Phil phone has to
have be in this team he's too big of a
talent so I would start with Phil fallen
on this side
and I'll be pushing him to make more
runs in behind but
I think uh you know for Gareth you may
look at steiling but I think phone but
he started the last Euros tournament
over the phone and second ended up
taking his place because he just didn't
perform an English hit we need to see
the full phone of man city in an English
yet okay Fordham would be mine as well
just I don't think you can leave him out
I think he's that he's that good he's
got that much ability
um he is one of our star players I think
and again very much like Harry he has to
do well
um I get I understand the pace bit we've
got to get in behind
but with with the former raheems in and
really has struggled without doubt for
me um Phil fordon would start so if that
front three of Saka Kane and Fordham
excites me me too that's a really strong
Frontier actually I really enjoy that
one
now we're just going to start with this
one here the holding Midfield role
are you both going for Declan rice yes
yeah why
do I think there's anyone bear for
England in that position
and I think because of our insecurities
in the center of positions
he will have to give a help and hand out
and give BR a little bit of protection
in there um
sort of Declan rice for me without a
doubt
I think for him as a player you know
West Ham fans might may not like it but
he is a guy who should be in teams that
are competing for the league title and
the champions league is that good I
think he's absolutely fantastic he
reminds me of Roy Keane that's the
player I sorted when I look at sort of
Roy Keane and how he played football was
not just defined in one position he was
he was an all-round Midfield player if
you like him that's who I see him
alongside just a bit nicer
[Laughter]
what are you thinking why don't you go
first Bellingham nice Bellingham
this this guy could light the tournament
up he could be one of the superstars of
the tournament we've we've seen what
he's doing in the Champions League uh
we've seen what he's doing
uh in German football or Bundesliga and
we've seen flashes of that for England
um and
he could be an England team for a for
many many years ahead and he could light
up this tournament he's one that could
be a superstar
and he's captaining that side as well
for the age that he is for being such a
baby it's almost like he's he's not
overwhelmed in any situation and the
courage he alongside a lot of other
young English players to go abroad at
such a young age a sample of different
sort of Lifestyle style of football I
think it's been a fantastic move for him
it looks like he's going to get another
move I would imagine in the summer
Liverpool whole friend oh he's a
Liverpool fan but if we can leave yeah
but no I think he's a player who
Real Madrid will want Barcelona will
want uh every top club in England will
want
and he looks but him and rice is
England's midfield for the next five or
six years don't think anyone's looking
at them and thinking they've got to take
those positions to be honest and they
probably won't be back on over who's the
future Captain after Harry Kane uh but
yeah Jude Bellingham I mean I said rice
reminds me of Roy Keane Jude Bellingham
reminds me of Steven gerrards at that
age where he just you think he could you
know score a goal anytime create
something at any time and uh yeah I
agree with that only could lights up
that tournament okay he's gonna go there
then Jamie who you want there
we we haven't got Midfield players in
abundance uh we we had Calvin Phillips
in the last Squad Jordan Henderson
didn't make it through injury we're now
two years on
I think Jordan Henderson will be in the
squad I think he finds it difficult to
be in the team right now I mean the only
one because the game is around and it's
a game we should win would be Mason
mount
yeah because I think he's uh he's a
creative player but he also gives you
that work I think off the ball you know
closing down pressing people and I just
don't think we have too many there but
if I'm being honest at Midfield I'm
picking here for the Iran game I don't
see that as a midfield for England going
forward in that 200 to come up against
top opposition okay
uh Mason shout would you like to
disagree or agree with that Alan
I can't disagree too much with it I
would I would chuck Madison in there as
well Madison would without doubt be in
my squad um I think he offers something
different
but for the Iran game
I'm afraid I after I agree with the with
mount in the um I like who he is I like
what he can offer
um but definitely I would look at
putting Madison in in at some stage
because he offers something slightly
different in the squad of the team in
the in the team I would definitely have
him in the squad but for the first game
possibly yeah I would I would it
wouldn't bother me if Mount or Madison
was in there um but I can't argue
against mount I do I do like Madison as
another option would you have Madison in
Squad yes would you have me in the team
at the point no I don't if I'm being
honest though when I see this team
getting all attacking players and it
looks really exciting England can't win
the world cup with that team right why
it's too offensive it's too open you
know we've rightly said the center-backs
are not our strongest position you'd
need more than declaration sitting there
if you don't really flare players like
battling in my mind going forward this
is for the Iran game but you'd have to
be a lot more pragmatic if anything want
to go further in the tournament okay
guys we're gonna move to left back now
um Jamie why don't you pick this one
first I'll go for Luke Shaw he's got
himself back into the Manchester United
Team he was the the England left back or
left wing back in the Euros I think he
scored in the final didn't he yeah so
you know so remember what happened yeah
yeah no I go for Luke Shaw I think he's
always had that
potential to dominate that position for
England hasn't quite happened for them
for different reasons at Manchester
United but they always go back to him
even a managers brought in a different
left back at different times they always
go back to Luke Shaw and I think he's
England's best left back by by streets
trippier
I would have I would find trippier a
place in the in the team whether it's
right back or left button why um because
he's that good is he yeah how's he
playing for Newcastle brilliant trippy
has he's been the game changer for
Newcastle he's he's better than Walker
defensively he's better than Trent
defensively he's better than Reese James
defensively he scored set pieces free
kicks he can put the ball on the money
in terms from a corner and that's why
I'd have him in the team set pieces will
be hugely important as you know England
have been successful with set pieces
um I don't think we'll have to do too
much defense defending anyway in that
Iran game so if he's not right back he's
without doubt left back no I don't see
that at all I see Kian chippy is a very
good Premier League player the players
were talking about him being up against
Carl walk on multiple Champion League
titles Trent Alexander Arnold the same
Champions League winners reached James
Champions League winner Luke Shaw just a
left foot I think when you're playing
against the circle yeah yeah not just
premier league but like yeah I'm well
aware of that and they got rid of him
and give them to Newcastle and then
you've got Luke Shaw you've been against
weaker opposition what's trouble this
year Wicked opposition
and that left foot going forward I think
is a massive difference I don't unders I
mean I like hearing shipping as a player
I don't understand the the left back
thing I don't even know where that's
come from I know we actually played
there for England
uh in the last tournament but I think
he's a good solid Premier League player
and uh I don't think he should be
getting in a fullback he'd be in the in
the in the squad no doubt but I don't
see how he plays in this team oh no this
means I've got to make the final
decision between Luke Shaw and Karen
trippy and do I effectively prefer Jamie
or Alan we've made it we've made it easy
for you up to now wow I would say
because my dad's a Geordie I'm gonna go
yes
okay guys we're gonna move uh to the
goalkeeping position and it took what
that was our 10th try to get you two to
disagree so do you think you're going to
agree on the keeper who who's your
number one I think it has to be Pickford
because of
well he's been superb for England I and
and Gareth um in in the in when he's
played and
it's not as if he's having a terrible
time with uh with Everett and he's
pulling off some magnificent saves so
I get why Gareth is one of gareth's
go-to guys where he even even when he
has been criticized Gareth still picked
him feels like there's a problem and I
understand that so yeah Pickford for me
there's a there's a big shout for the
other two in
I mean pork's been a game changer for
Newcastle not as not as good with his uh
off off the deck as um his pick for this
so yeah Pickford for me
pickford's are shooting I think he's one
of those just behind how he came where
it is almost a guarantee to play I think
I'd have to selgate would always pick
him he's never let England down at times
his phone's been up and down forever and
going back a few years but I think since
Frank vampire come in he's been
outstanding for a for Evan as well and
also his ability with you know the
Boneless feet all right Bigfoot goes
there there we go I'm having second
thoughts about the left right position
guys
you can still change it it's really
difficult isn't it you're playing around
you want a right foot to that left back
yeah
he's let me convince really is there any
more questions
Jude battling a Mason Mount okay that's
a good point there we go all right I've
changed my mind Luke Shaw's going in but
gives you a bit of an insight into how
difficult it is to be the England
manager really doesn't it are we happy
with the 11 apart from the left back
position yeah I think we've agreed on on
most things I mean I wouldn't be unhappy
with Shaw in there left back if not
don't we I'm not disrespectful to him
but
I think that's as
yeah I mean I'll play Four as we said so
yeah I'm quite happy with that too do
you think that team going forward can
win a World Cup did that actual set that
system how offensive we are in Midfield
you think that's the way to win a
tournament
no I didn't I'm not convinced it would
if if they were playing
France in the last 16 or or whoever a
top team in the quarter-final and I
don't think he would play so it could be
called yeah I think that would be it
that
um I wouldn't be too worried about a
Holland or maybe maybe France I would be
I'd be worried about or if it was
further on a quarter final whoever
whoever it may be how did you change it
I would have a bit more protection I
wouldn't be comfortable defensively so I
would have to have some more protection
in front of the year in front of that
that back four whether he would put
Henderson in there alongside race so it
would still be a battlefield yeah four
two three one yeah I'd go for it back
three
in those games because I don't think the
actual Midfield we've got you could put
Jordan in there but in terms of having
that energy to sort of protect the back
uh for so I think Alan's right if you go
to back for you you're definitely almost
gonna have two players who don't move
and I don't think we've got enough of
those in the squad so I think you could
still have rice almost sitting alone if
you like and still getting help from
Midfield but as long as you had three
behind him so and maybe one of the wing
back so you've always got a four or five
players behind the ball so that's that's
why I would go for the back three and
then Garrett's had success doing that
against big nation certainly in the last
tournament he did that in the final uh
against Italy obviously lost the game I
think he did against Germany so whenever
you come against soccer position it's a
system he's always gone back to what
would be success for this England team
in this tournament the World Cup and
what would Gareth need to secure the
next contract
I think semi-final
I don't I hope I'm wrong but I don't see
us being I don't get I don't see us get
into a semi or the final I don't see
it's gone as far as we have done in the
last two tournaments because I don't
fanciest defensively I hope I'm wrong
um what does Gareth have to do
he'll he'll decide that I think he'll
decide when he leaves England and I
think that's the right decision for him
because of his
success if you like and where he's where
he's taken this England team yeah he
hasn't it I mean I don't go along with
all the crap about
that he's sometimes he's negative or the
criticism if you look at if you look at
a lot of European countries leading up
to this world cup a lot of them are
struggling there has to be a reason for
that England are one of them so and you
get on a bit of a snowball a snowball
effective you get confidence on the
first three games and you just never
know so a quarter final for me would and
then he's got England to a quarterfinal
a semi-final and a final I mean look at
where we were before that we were we
were garbage before that
so he's got us to that final to that
semi-final I think it should be his
decision when he choose to leave England
not the other way around do you agree
with that it should be his decision but
if I was out at Southgate and this no
matter what happened in this tournament
I would walk away
you can just feel the and our nose is
better than anyone when they're sort of
the feel and whether it's the supporters
the media just start to turn on the
manager and I think it's being
completely bang out of order the
reaction that we've seen in the last 12
months what the England manager has done
now get at Southgate put him right up
there you know probably just behind
Sarah Ramsey uh in what he's done you
think of all the managers who've done
read about Bobby Robson or two
semi-final Terry venables but he's done
it twice in two-tone and semi-final and
final so he's done a brilliant job but
for me I I think if if england don't get
to a semi-final I think there'll be a
lot of negativity around around the
England manager the England team and I
don't agree with that but I think it'd
be best for all if
if Gareth moved on
after the tournament because I think he
just get this to him out the way he
doesn't need that negativity really
because he's done an absolutely
fantastic job there we go guys that's
your 11 against Iran for England the
first game of the World Cup not too many
disagreements I think that's quite a
good team are you guys are you happy
I feel that out happy with that team
should win against Iran excellent cheers
still friends I love it
foreign
[Music]
people say maybe not have the mobility
but he's just I like him he works hard
yeah